امبراطوريتان عسكريتان قامتا على انقاض
حكم البشير رجلان الحكم العسكري في
السودان نفايا مرارا وجود اي خلاف بينهما
وحجم التراشق الكلامي في خانه حرب زائفه
ابتدعت اعلاميا بهدف خرق الصف الواحد الا
انه ما انزلق للمواجهه المسلحه
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد القوات البريه في
عهد البشير صار قائدا للجيش النظامي فيما
اسست ثاني اي محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحميتي قوات الدعم السريع معتمدا
عالميليشياتا خاضت حربا داميه في دارفور
لكنه لم يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في
الدوله او النائب
تهديد فعلي شكله حميتي للبرهان معززا
امبراطوريته بجيش خاص قوامه 100,000 عنصر
اي ما يوازي تقريبا حجم قوات الجيش
السوداني فضلا عن تكسب اقتصادي نتج عن عقد
صفقات مع شركات دوليه
في الاتفاق الايطالي اداه للمحافظه على
مكتسباته لكن التوقيع فشل مرتين بسبب
خلافات حول دمج قوه الدعم السريع في الجيش
ومداه الزمني ووضعيه قياده القوات ففي حين
اراد البرهان اتمام الدمج وفقا لقواعد
الجيش وانظمته تمسك احمدتي باعاده هيكله
قياده الجيش العليا اولا حتى يكون جزءا
منها قبل دمج قواته وتقليص نفوذه نازل
قضايا خلافيه اخرى شقت طريقها الى
المنظومه الامنيه مثل اصلاح الجيش وابعاد
انصار النظام السابق عنه كما مثلت اداره
الملفات الخارجيه ونسج نائب البرهان
لعلاقات عابره للحدود تحديا كبيرا
للجانبين فاحمد التي متهم من قبل الجيش
بخلق علاقات دبلوماسيه موازيه للدوله